how do you want the everyday basketball
fan to view it at midday badass right do
you have to say that LeBron is a male
basketball player like I don't
understand why we have to do that it
felt like so much of my life was hidden
from even members of my family am on my
way to DC to link up with Washington
Mystics forward Elena Delle Donne
bouncing back from an injury she has a
lot to prove this season but she's
already proving why more people need to
take notice of the WNBA we're gonna do
like a side by side old now yeah what
happened to us
1990
you have been called the best free-throw
shooter in pro basket
are you the best free-throw shooter in
pro basketball I don't know I mean maybe
but I think you know like it's not a
title I've like tape I just know that I
have kind of just figured out what works
for me and the simplicity of the shot
and not letting my mind get too involved
because free-throw shooting is so mental
so what does work for you when it comes
to shooting business making it the same
and keeping it very simple so like I
literally get a 90 degree angle with my
arm and then lift and flick and that's
really it
you'll see players like get up there and
spin the ball or like put it behind
their back or between their legs and
when you do that so much can go wrong
like you will be thinking about that
when you take your shot and that's just
your routine like why should your
routine affect the shot oh my goodness
what do you prefer to be described as
basketball player or female basketball
player basketball player do you have to
say that LeBron is a male basketball
player like I don't understand why we
have to do that like we're basketball
players we play basketball how do you
want the everyday basketball fan to view
the WNBA badass badass mask is badass
basketball
how does the everyday basketball fan
view the WNBA I think the true fan are
someone who has played basketball and
truly knows the game loves it I mean you
hear the NBA guys talk about it they
watch our games they study our games to
learn stuff from us
it's those high school husbands that
think they can still play and for some
reason hate that females might be better
than them at something they're the ones
who struggle to jump on board when
someone says that women's basketball is
fundamental basketball how do you view
that term fundamental that word just
it's a little boring it's almost like
they're kind of just simplifying our
game and saying like it's very
fundamental and you know it's way
different than the NBA like we can't
just jump over people and dunk like a
lot of times we have to get to the rim
and get real creative and all different
finishes so the game is different but I
don't think there needs to be that
comparison all the time and even just
the small little naysayers who are
constantly like on us like go back to
the kitchen go back to the kitchen what
is it with the kitchen like what is the
kitchen comment I can't hear at least
say order post mates or something more
accurate yeah you talked about the
marketing of WNBA players and I know
that last year you called out Adam
Silver for not investing enough
marketing dollars into the game you
can't make a business plan 20 years ago
and keep it the same for 20 years you
know it's got to change as the times
have changed and now is the time where
you know women are at the forefront of
so much and women are so powerful and
motivational so I think the W can be
something that women can look to for
that inspiration
there's this idea though that if we talk
about anything that has to do with a
woman we almost do it in a comparison to
a man that's like something I've always
struggled with there's been so many NBA
guys talking about the WNBA and it's
frustrating that they have to talk about
it for us to be legit and people do
listen when they talk and unfortunately
people aren't listening as much as when
we talk why can't we just be heard what
NBA players really do support the league
I mean
LeBron even during our playoffs like I
was able to meet up with him because I
was doing the barbershop
he was just like spitting out stats and
all this stuff like in this game this
minute why did this happen you need to
do this you need to speak out like it
was great and it was just like normal
basketball talk and I was like okay like
you truly watch
what does gender equity look like in the
WNBA we're not asking for NBA money we
know that our league is not generating
the dollars that the NBA is but we do
deserve more than we get the more and
more we get marketing dollars behind it
we get to be on TV more that's when we
can continue to grow and salaries will
continue to grow so for someone who says
okay well maybe you guys don't get
enough because not enough people watch
what would your response be to that the
WNBA playoffs
we're on ESPN news so like it was really
able to watch like I've always said the
WNBA fans are probably the most loyal
fans there are because you have to be
able to sign up for League Pass to be
able to watch most of the games or
follow your favorite team or like say
you want to buy a hat a lot a lot of
times there's one hat you can choose
from like you can't rock really cool
hats it has to be so frustrating you see
when you talk about your like and they
can't they don't even have a hat you get
a hat yeah we're like they can't even
get a kid sized jersey at times that's
the stuff that's frustrating but I have
seen a little bit more of a ship with
the Women's World Cup coming out like
there's a lot that is about to happen
this summer how did it feel for you to
see like the Women's World Cup stuff and
the soccer players saying hey we're
gonna take a stand against this yeah
it's inspiring to everybody else looking
up to them and seeing like you know this
is wrong like let's fix it they just had
the game where they wore a female that
inspires them Beyonce was on a jersey
like Lorde was on a Jersey and then
there was delle donne I was like wow
like this is pretty cool if you were to
wear a Jersey whose name would you put
on the back I think pink
she's just constantly spoke her mind and
done what's right and even if it has
hurt her at times like she didn't care
she always just kind of did the right
thing
she's just so powerful and so important
to women so you live in DC you can't
really get away from the politics being
here as being in this environment forced
you to be less silent about political
things that you feel matter I think just
what's going on in politics right now
has forced me to really try to speak up
who we have in office is well
frightening at the moment what's going
on and just I don't know the hatred that
is being brought up is scary to me yeah
we've got to speak up and I know it gets
tiring every day something new to kind
of say no stop this is wrong but we kind
of just got to keep pushing you've been
in the news a couple times you had a
disagreement with Adam silver you wrote
a book what inspired you to just be more
vocal truly just meeting Amanda my wife
made me feel at home and she's just
helped me grow up and kind of just be
Who I am and not be apologetic about it
when you first meet her she like comes
off as like very serious sometimes
she'll have I don't know if I should say
this but like that resting [ __ ] you
can say okay the resting [ __ ] but
she truly has one of the biggest hearts
I've ever seen and for those she cares
about she goes above and beyond like she
runs all my businesses she she's doing
the renovations so tell me what that
process has been like that's been quite
fun so we we decided to buy this house
and we knew it was gonna take some like
fixing basically Amanda kind of had the
vision she was all over Pinterest and I
was like do you like this yes yes and
worked with the contractor to get it
done Amanda your wife told me you are
the boss you're in control so I want to
know what it's been like to lose control
of your house for all these months
terrible we're going in our basement
with our two dogs yeah they're not small
dogs there's that and I'd like to think
you put in some I said you would show me
Pinterest and then I'd say
that's the process yeah it was really
amazing here like I talked about you I
said I was the goofy one and you're the
drying humor yeah you're weird it's not
a bad I think it's great to be weird
actually people don't really know her
I think they've gotten to know you
better their Instagram because I would
love just recording her so people can
see what she's really like because she's
funnier for sure thank you
growing up and being a lesbian and not
really understanding what was going on
not really having a role model to look
to and just feeling like I had to keep
that hidden was really tough it felt
like so much of my life was hidden from
even members of my family and then when
I met Amanda it just all kind of changed
cheers to the d'Elegance we do a segment
with every guest I'm gonna tell you
about a time or a moment you're gonna
take me to that time or moment okay all
righty take me to when you met your dog
I was in Chicago and the breeder brought
him he got out of the little car and
he's like flopping around his ears were
here just Paul's were huge it was love
at first sight take me to your TV guilty
pleasure okay so I loved how to get away
with murder but then I love MTV the
challenge definitely my biggest skill T
you're on Shonda Rhimes now when we
first met we were talking about how much
we love scam exactly yeah anything Sean
does got out come for it take me to the
time you realized hey I'm tall oh oh my
goodness and when I came out of the womb
now I'm just kidding oh I think when I
like was in school and we started doing
like school plays you know how you do
like one a year
and like I was always in the back row
for singing parts with like all the tall
boys and then me and then even like when
we could watch the videos back and like
watch what we're doing in the dances
that's like my goodness I am really tall
now you mentioned some accommodations
with the house because you yeah all
right all person this light tell me
about the light so this used to be like
a drop-down light and like right when I
first came into the house it was like Oh
knocked myself out so I'm not gonna get
concussed walking into my home and
Eric's
lots of stuffs happening in here we've
got paint did you guys ever think about
doing the painting yourself it's simple
but it's a headache and it's tedious
yeah when you paint yourself you see all
the things that like you didn't do
perfectly we're like I don't see that
and I'm sure they paint better than I do
oh yeah I think we can leave it to the
profession yeah so now that you feel you
have found your voice mm-hmm
what do you want people to hear I want
females to be empowered and to be strong
and if I can say something to inspire
you know the next coming up then I've
done my job and if I just you know kept
going the way I first started the game
where I was just like just the lane of
the basketball player I don't have
opinions that wasn't doing me any good
and it wasn't doing anyone else good so
I want to leave this game better than I
came into it and hopefully inspire the
young ones to speak their mind and keep
pushing find the good light the right
angle Sierra you know I do just wrapped
up with Elena Delle Donne which looks
such a great name thank you like it's it
is okay so how do we say it like del
adore named Bella Donna
[Music]
hello guys it is Taylor rooks thank you
so much for watching my show take it
there but now you have to subscribe you
don't want to miss the next interview
and all the fun stuff we're doing on the
YouTube channel so hit that subscribe
button two things see you guys soon